vous êtes vous déjà demandé ce qui peut
bien se passer on a fait au moins 272 la
banque philippe et c'est une catastrophe
a parlé de cette odeur était on va
passer une belle journée qui deviendra
une belle semaine qui deviendra une
belle année qui deviendra ligue 1 on va
faire la liste complète de tous qui
devrait enthousiasmer parmi les pires
scénarios on n'a pas être interrogée par
le professeur l es tu veux bien
présenter en quelques mots
on ne va pas faire ça elle prend
toujours des rôles je suis trop triste
pour j'ai deux filles hyper cool à 2
heures vers l'or paris gr palace est pas
question de leur parler ce qu'on veut
c'est qu'elle nous aiment sur fermé à
double tour et lourds les le second
volet ça donne le rythme à sa vie vous
n'êtes pas obligés de venir à tous mes
marques sont énormes quoi tu plaisantes
je ne peux pas rater un alors là si tous
connus
tu es sûr que ça va je sais pas de quoi
on parle et la porte de poids pour la
pâture par newlin attendu va te perdre
soi positive je suis positivement sûr
que tu vas te perdre
comment s'est passé ce premier jour
d'école donc mais perthois tous ses
biens d'acier ok je n'aime pas du tout
ce genre d'attitude est sévère il fait
encore ses yeux de merlan frit c'est
pour ça qu'on a largué notre pilote
d'hélicoptère brésilien vient en vaudois
avec moi petit char